tenemos fx igual a 9 x al cuadrado y gtx
igual a 5 x al cuadrado más 2 x más 1 y
nos piden determinar
efe g de x esto se ve un poco extraño
verdad
efe más head x de hecho esa es la parte
clave del problema es saber qué
significa esta anotación y cuando
alguien escribe efe gx esto simplemente
es una abreviación para denotar lo
siguiente
efe gx f más g de x simplemente es igual
esto es una nueva función verdad
evaluada en x pero simplemente la
función que se obtiene a partir de sumar
fx
x y g de x entonces como puedes ver es
algo bastante sencillo una vez que
sabemos de qué se trata la anotación
básicamente hay que sumar efe con g efe
lo tenemos aquí es 9 menos x al cuadrado
entonces estoy aquí sería 99 menos x al
cuadrado ya eso tendríamos que sumar g g
que es esta de acá
que sería que sería 55 x al cuadrado más
2 x más 1 muy bien déjame realizar la
operación voy a copiar estos numeritos
para no equivocarme entonces sería 9
menos x al cuadrado y a eso tenemos que
sumarle tenemos que sumarle 5x cuadrada
más 2 x más 1 muy bien vamos a ver que
nos da entonces esto de aquí es igual a
ya no voy a quedar en color amarillo es
igual a este paréntesis lo podemos
quitar 9 - x cuadrada este también
porque estamos sumando si estuviéramos
restando habría que distribuir pero aquí
nada más sumamos entonces podemos poner
más 5 x cuadrada más 2 x más 1 y
finalmente podemos juntar términos
similares términos que tengan el mismo
grado por ejemplo
aquí tenemos este este 5x cuadrado y
este menos x cuadrada 5x cuadrada menos
y menos
x cuadrada son 4 x cuadrada 4 x cuadrada
luego vamos con los términos que tienen
x así solita que es nada más este 2x más
2 x y finalmente tenemos los términos
constantes y los términos constantes son
este 9 y este 1 y 9 más uno es igual a
entonces nos queda 4x cuadrada más 2 x
más 10 de esta forma vemos que f g
efe + g evaluado en x es igual a 4x
cuadrada más 2 x más 10 entonces es
bastante sencillo de lo único que
tenemos que acordarnos es que f g
evaluado en un punto es sumar en las
funciones evaluadas en ese punto